bienvenue à tous c'est l'heure de
Parlement Hebdo 45 minutes pour faire le
tour de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire avec Katia guilder bonjour
Katia bonjour Mel et cette semaine dans
l'actualité le Premier ministre qui est
sur tous les fronts et ça commence à
Londres en visite à la City il a déclaré
sa flamme à l'entreprise et en anglais
s'il vous plaît my government business
mais le débat a surtout été lancé après
avoir laissé entendre qu'il pourrait
réformer l'assurance chômage débat
légitime dit-il dans son propre camp
tous ne sont pas d'accord une épreuve de
force et une négociation à haut risque
s'engage entre Paris et Bruxelles la
France doit envoyer son projet de budget
à la commission mais pour le moment ça
coince Bruxelles peut-il retoquer ce
budget ce sera notre zoom de la semaine
et puis c'est un coup de grâce pour les
cotax et goen Royal ami fin au
feuilleton a-t-elle plié face à la
menace des routiers manuel bal salue lui
une décision sage à alors que la
transition énergétique est en cours
d'examen à l'Assemblée nationale les
verrs sont furieux et justement notre
invité cette semaine François de rugi
bonjour député de Loire Atlantique et
coprésident du groupe écologiste à
l'Assemblée nationale beaucoup
d'actualité pour vous on va en parler
mais d'abord vous n'échapperez pas à la
tradition de cette émission on a demandé
à quelquesuns de vos collègues ce qu'il
pensaient de vous écoutez il n'est pas
simplement le porte-parole de lui-même
et en cela je l'apprécie parce que je
sais qu'on peut avec lui c'est pas le
cas de tous les députés écologistes et
je trouve que il incarne bien l'écologie
moderne ça on ne peut pas lui reprocher
d'avoir été défendre un point de vue qui
n'avait pas été validé par le par le
groupe et même s'il est en opposition
avec la vie que le groupe a donné il il
le défend jusqu'au bout je l'admire pour
ça parce que c'est pas facile c'est un
exercice très compliqué à faire j'ai du
respect de l'estime pour tous ceux qui
dans cet hémicycle comme j'essaie de le
faire défendent les choses dans
lesquelles il croi quoi que ça coûte
quelle que soit l'heure du jour et de la
nuit et queles que soient les
circonstances et ça ça s'estime si je
peux faire un reproche à Monsieur drugi
c'est que il a le il a le bon mot un peu
facile peut-être que il gagnerait en
percussion de temps en temps à être un
peu moins mordant et un peu plus d'une
forme douce c'est ce que je pense en
tout cas voilà pour on voir si vous êtes
plus doux on va rigoler on va voir ça
vous êtes à la tête d'un groupe qui a
presque autant de voix différentes que
de membres pourquoi tout ce toute cette
cacophonie comment vous faites pour eu
non franchement je crois que vous savez
tous les groupes parlementaires à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat euh
ont des individualités forte d'ailleurs
pour une raison simple mais chez vous il
y en a beaucoup hein Cécile Duff ça
êtreoui si vous voulez que l'on parle
desffondeurs du parti socialistes des
divisions au sein de l'UMP vous parlez à
tout le monde au sein de votre groupe
sans problème ah oui nous essayons
toujours de construire des positions
collectives et puis quand vraiment ce
n'est pas possible on va pas faire
semblant donc il nous est arrivé d'avoir
des des votes différents au sein du
groupe et de dire pourquoi et en quelque
sorte on fait œuvre de transparence nous
nous préférons avec barbara Pompili les
deux co-présidents de groupe que nous
sommes déjà d'ailleurs le fait d'avoir
deux co-présidents c'était une volonté
de collégialité bien avoir des positions
évidemment commune après oui il y a des
personnalités au sein du groupe et bon
ça fait aussi partie non seulement de la
vie politique mais de la vie tout court
et vous gêne pas trop Cécile dufl je me
répète mais je vous pose quand même les
questions non maisou pourquoi voudre
voudriez-vous que cela nous gêne
nous avons une députée de plus nous
étions 17 nous sommes maintenant 18 et
par ailleurs elle a une expérience qui
est précieuse qui est celle du
gouvernement et elle est la seule au
sein du groupe écologiste d'ailleurs à
avoir cette expérience gouvernementale
peut-être qu'un jour il y en aura
d'autres mais pour l'instant elle est la
seule et c'est une expérience précieuse
qu'elle peut nous faire partager alors
on reviendra un petit peu plus sur vous
sur votre iréputation tout ce que vous
faites sur le web ça sera à la fin de
cette émission mais on va commencer par
dérouler la semaine et ça commence par
un lundi manuel Vals est à la
City
alors vous connaissiez le geme
l'entreprise en version française en
version allemande ben la VO ça la voici
maintenant en version anglaise il était
dans le temple de la finance à Londres
Ahmed
Tazir à Londres un des fiefs du France
bashing manuel Vals n'est pas en terrain
conquis et il le sait poigné de main
virile avec son homologue britannique
devant le 10 Downing Street la rencontre
intervient alors que la France se voir
reprocher de ne pas en faire assez pour
réduire ses déficits David Cameron lui
conduit une politique d'austérité
budgétaire qui s'accompagne cette année
d'une prévision de forte croissance de
3,5 %. devant les caméras le Premier
ministre britannique reste diplomate
bien que nous soyons issus de familles
politiques différentes je suis certain
que nous avons beaucoup à partager en
terme d'expérience oui je suis ravi de
vous accueillir
ici mais le créau de Manuel Vals c'est
l'entreprise après l'avoir répété devant
le mdeef devant les patrons allemands
fin
il le redit à la City de Londres le
temple de la finance mondiale et en
anglais s'il vous
plaît j'aime les entreprises grâce à la
traduction vous
l'entendez mais je vais le dire en
anglais d'une autre manière parce que
c'est important de le dire ici à la Cité
my
governmentsiness et l'on découvre am
manuel Vals polyglotte un discours
éloigné de celui de François Hollande
pour qui l'adversaire c'était la finance
le Premier ministre poursuiv à tournée
au Pays-Bas et au Luxembourg le 20
octobre alors vous aussi vous êtes pro
business on attend la traduction donc
néerlandaise avec impatience plus
sérieusement je crois que c'est un peu
un faux débat ça moi aller à la City et
non pas à la cité comme l'a dit le
Premier ministre à la City de Londres je
vois pas tellement l'intérêt je le dis
franchement le symbole me paraît pas
très bon pourquoi aller chercher des
espèces de brevets de respectabilité
là-bas avoir des échanges avec les
britanniquesux réformer montr que je
réforme oui mais je crois pas vous savez
je crois pas que la City soit un exemple
de réforme et d'esprit réformateur je
vais vous dire pourquoi parce que chaque
fois qu'on a essayé de réformer la
finance qui est trop spéculative chacun
en convient et bien qui est-ce qui s'est
opposé avec vraiment de la façon la plus
farouche possible c'est le gouvernement
britannique sous la pression de la City
en revanche que l'on dise pour répondre
à votre première question my government
is pro business mon gouvernement est pro
business et que ça ça fasse quasiment la
une des médias li Branton vous imaginez
un Premier ministre qui aurait dit je
suis anti s je n'aime pas les entrepris
je déteste les entreprises mais ce
serait absurde pas de l'entreprise mais
de la finance par exemple parce qu'on
était à Londres on était à Londres et en
fait le business c'est quand même plus
large que la finance je l'espère ou
alors si le business anglais la finance
c'estésespérant crtique Françis
d'origine était bien au début sur la
critique de la finance on a bien compris
ce que vous voulez dire on est loin
quand même on est loin quand même du
discours de François Holland bourg mon
ennemi c'est la finance il y a là c'est
sûr un décalage je pense pas que ce
décalage soit très bon mais vous savez
cette phrase aussi sur mon ennemi c'est
la finance voilà ça c'est des phrases de
campagne euh qui sont des symboles et
puis après alors on joue avec les
symboles et à force de jouer uniquement
avec les symboles la politique elle
n'avance pas beaucoup mais ce symbole a
fait le tour de nos de la presse de nos
partenaires européens qui retiennent
cette image de d'un Premier ministre
socialiste qui vient à Londres avec ce
genre de de phrase qui qui représente
finalement la la la France des réformes
celle qui marche c'est plutôt une bonne
chose ça pour notre pays non bah que le
premier ministre aille vendre en quelque
sorte la France et qu'il aille expliquer
sa politique dans d'autres pays chez nos
voisins c'est tout à fait positif
évidemment et ça prouve d'ailleurs qu'il
y a pas que le Président de la
République qui s'occupe de d'action
internationale moi je préfère c'est vrai
quand il va en Italie avec mattho Renzi
où là je crois qu'il peut y avoir un axe
qui est à la fois réformateur
pro-européen mais qui dit la politique
européenne doit changer ça ça me paraît
beaucoup plus intéressant vous parliez
de de symbole tout à l'heure et je vous
disais tout à l'heure aussi que mon
ademi c'était la finance vous l'avez
rappelé c'était une phrase qui date de
2012 nous sommes en 2014 c'est fini ce
temps-là pour ce gouvernement non parce
que je crois pas que je crois pas que le
gouvernement soit devenu l'ami de la
finance encore une fois toutes ces
phrases on en crève on étouffe d'être
uniquement sur les symboles des totems
soyons dans le concret et le concret
c'est aussi cette taxe à 75 % qui ou la
taxe sur les transaction financière sur
laquelle on avance mais en effet qui
est-ce qui résiste c'est le gouvernement
britannique et c'est la City et par
ailleurs un événement ça on en parle peu
la désignation des commissaires
européens et je trouve ça assez grave
que parmi ces commissaires il y a un
commissaire anglais qui soit justement
chargé de alors on en parle la politique
économique de la France est aussi
regardé par Bruxelles qui surveille
désormais de très près le budget de
Paris la France devra-t-elle revoir son
projet de budget pour 2015 Bruxelles n'a
encore rien dit mais la rumeur a couru
suscitant interrogation et indignation à
l'Assemblée mardi notamment lors des
questions au gouvernement c'est l'état
l'avis n'est pas encore officiel mais la
rumeur s'est vite répandue la Commission
européenne pourrait demander à Paris de
revoir son projet de budget pour 2015 à
l'Assemblée l'opposition s'est
immédiatement emparé du
sujet la France Monsieur le Premier
Ministre n'a pas le droit à l'erreur
sous peine de se voir mise sous tutelle
par la Commission européenne les baisses
d'impôts et de cotisation en faveur des
entrepris les baisses d'impôts en faveur
des ménages la diminution des dépenses
ce sont exactement les chiffres que nous
avons annoncés au printemps dernier
exactement les mêmes même effort même
clou mêmes engagements il n'y a aucune
raison d'être en contradiction avec les
règles européennes quelques minutes plus
tard le gouvernement est à nouveau
interpellé cette fois c'est Manuel Vals
qui défend les engagements de la France
allez-vous enclencher réellement les
réformes nécessaires à notre pays
qu'alz-vous enfin répondre à Bruxelles
et à nos partenaires monsieur le député
je vous le demande plutôt que de
critiquer la France plutôt que de vousis
de je ne sais quelle thèse qui ne vient
pas de notre pays alors faites des
propositions des propositions crédibles
oui je vous attends sur ce débat mais
pas sur je ne sais quelle accusation sur
je ne sais quelle rumeur le budget de la
France c'est le budget qu'il faut pour
notre pays depuis 2013 Bruxelles
contrôle les budgets de chaque État
membre et peut décider de sanctionner
financièrement les mauvais élèves selon
la rumeur il manquerait entre 6 et 8
milliards d'économies supplémentaires
pour que le déficit français soit dans
les clous du pacte de stabilité al on va
en parler François de rugie mais d'abord
revenons sur ce nouveau pouvoir de la
Commission européenne pouvoir de
contrôle et de sanction des mauvais
élèves c'est le zoom de la
semaine Clémentine fuicier nous a
rejoint sur ce plateau bonjour vous êtes
rédactrice en chef de contexte site
d'information en ligne sur l'Europe la
politique européenne vous connaissez les
arcanes de Bruxelles dites-nous comment
cette rumeur a pu arriver en France
cette rumeur elle est pas très étonnante
en fait chacun joue un peu son match la
Commission européenne fait passer des
messages par le BIS de la presse pour
dire attention là ça se passe pas
exactement comme ça devrait se passer
c'est vrai que les chiffres qui ont
fuité qui ont été annoncés ne sont pas
du tout dans les clous de ce qui avait
été prévu notamment on en reparlera
peut-être sur ce qui concerne le déficit
structurel alors c'est un peu technique
mais c'est ce qui concerne finalement le
déficit quand on a enlevé les
éléments du moment les éléments liés à
la mauvaise situation économique et donc
là voilà la Commission fait passer ses
messages par les de la prission euh on
dit que c'est l'entourage de du nouveau
président du nouveau président de la
commission don CLUD Junker qui fait
passer ses messages par quel est
l'intérêt François d'or de lancer ces
foles rumeurs oh je sais pas si c'est
des foles rumeurs il y a une situation
qui est bien connue d'abord en effet la
Commission européenne joue un rôle un
peu nouveau mais qui est nécessaire moi
je ne conteste pas cela parce que si on
veut avoir une monnaie unique qui
fonctionne mieux qui ne soit pas en
danger il faut qu'il y ait de la
coordination des politiques économiques
et budgétaires ça c'est normal après
chaque État reste évidemment maître de
son budget et la France a engagé un peu
un bras de fer disons-le par rapport à
la question du déficit des 3 % du
déficit du PIB et là je crois que c'est
pas à 6 ou 8 milliards parce qu'on va
être à 4 et5i % de déficit par rapport
au produits intérieur brut alors qu'il y
a eu des promesses régulières de faire 3
% nous nous l'avions dit en 2012 dire
l'année prochaine on fait 3 % alors que
c'est totalement hors de portée ce
n'était pas une bonne politique
qu'attend concrètement la Commission
européenne de la France qu'est-ce
qu'elle veut plus de réforme moins de
dépenses elle veut plus de réformes
et elle attend queil y a qu'il y ait
quand même quelques mesures un peu phare
et surtout je pense aussi elle attend de
pouvoir répondre aux États comme les
Espagnols par exemple qui ont fait des
efforts qui se sont coupés les bras sous
la pression des Européens et qui ont
voilà fait les efforts qu'il fallait que
les Français respectent un peu leurs
engagements on est quand même les seuls
à chaque fois à reporter d'année en
année les efforts qu'on doit faire donc
je pense que ce qu'elle attend c'est un
engagement plus précis des réformes qui
vont êtreel type de réform des réformes
peut-être plus structurelles alors on
verra ce qu'il y a dans le projet de loi
de d'Emmanuel Macron là qui se prépare
pas on dit à disé que en qu'il y a
peut-être des éléments supplémentaires
qui pourraient être ajoutés on verra ce
qu' sur les professions sur les
professions réglementées voilà sur le
débat qui va nous toucher bientôt à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat
bientôt sur le budget vous n'aurez aucun
pouvoir d'amendement si on comprend bien
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui tout est
bloqué tout est figé c'est pas ce que
nous dit le gouvernement et c'est pas ce
que dit le principal groupe de la
majorité qui est le le groupe socialiste
heureusement il y a du débat
parlementaire tous les ans sur le budget
marge de manœuvre ben il y en a peu ça
c'est vrai et c'est l'héritage d'années
et d'années de déficit je rappelle quand
même parce que moi j'étais député depuis
en 2007 dans l'opposition que le déficit
a commencé à réaugmenter avant la crise
c'est-à-dire que c'est à l'été 2007
quand Nicolas Sarkozi a voulu prendre
ses mesures du paquet fiscal qu'on a
fait redéraper le déficit donc en France
en effet quand on est plutôt en
situation économique relativement
confortable de croissance comme on dit
on ne réduit pas on ne profite pas de
ces périodes pour réduire la dette donc
lorsqu'il y a une crise et qu'en effet
là ce sera très logique de faire un peu
d'endettement pour financer des mesures
de relance et bien on se retrouve
complètement coincé ça c'est une
situation qui n'est plus tenable on le
voit aujourd'hui après il y a toujours
des marges de manœuvre parce que à
l'intérieur de l'enveloppe vous pouvez
toujours dire heureusement vous pouvez
faire des choix et moi je pense
d'ailleurs que le problème c'est que
depuis 2012 on n pas fait assez de choix
est-ce que Bruxelles a supplanté le le
le pouvoir budgétaire la commission elle
va pas sanctionner un budget Michel
Sapin a raison quand il dit que
techniquement la Commission peut pas
sanctionner elle peut pas sanctionner un
budget elle peut sanctionner un état qui
respecte pas ses engag mais je pense
qu'il faut pas se me prendre sur une
chose la sanction c'est l'arme atomique
elle aura non mais franchement elle aura
jamais lieu la la l'idée derrière c'est
la négociation et je pense que là chacun
est en train de négocier je pense que
c'est ça qu'on peut lâcher alors sur
quoi on peut lâcher bah écoutez ça c'est
le gouvernement qui répondra moi je
pense que de toute façon là aussi non
mais on est dans un mauvais je jeu de
rôle et là on vient d'en avoir
l'explication transparente c'estàd que
tout le monde joue au chat et à la
sourie le gouvernement dit si si si
depuis 2 ans et demi je vais tenir mes
engagements qui sait que c'est intenable
et depuis le gouvernement c'est que
c'est intenable sauf à avoir cru un je
de DUP sauf à avoir cru en un Paris qui
à mon avis là est en effet l'erreur
fondamentale de ce quinena qui est que
la croissance va revenir demain matin en
tout cas dans quelques mois ou dans un
an François deorugie l'erreur majeure de
François hand c'est d'avoir cru que la
croissance pourrait revenirou ah nous
nous le disons depuis 2 ans et demi donc
on se sent assez à l'aise pour le dire
nous n'avons jamais cru à un retour
comme ça rapide de la croissance qui
règlerait comme par miracle l'ensemble
des problèmes budgétaires fiscaux ci du
pays un mot de conclusion c'est Pierre
Moscovici qui sera chargé une finé de
contrôler tous les budgets c'est un
petit peu ironique ironie de l'histoire
surtout c'est que l'annonce a été faite
le jour de son audition à Bruxelles donc
c'est le cadeau de
bienvenue génial oui c'est lui qui va
être chargé de contrôler effectivement
si la France respecte pas ses
engagements il a dit que pour l'instant
il se prononçait pas sur le cas français
il a dit qu'il était là pour appliquer
les règles donc on verra on verra merci
beaucoup Clémentine for d'avoir été avec
nous sur ce plateau un petit mot quand
même sur Pierre Moscovici ça vous ça
vous surprends ça vous choque bah c'est
surtout moi je trouve que c'est pas une
très bonne idée de passer directement
enfin directement avec quelques mois
d'écart de ministre de l'Économie non
reconduit à ce poste manifestement ce
qu'on considérait quand même que la
politique économique était pas très bien
menée à ministre de l'économie de
l'Union européenne puisque c'est un peu
le poste qu'il est censé occuper au sein
de la Commission européenne voilà sur le
symbole après pierre moscovissi est un
homme compétent et talentueux donc ça on
va pas le remettre en cause à cette
occasion vous réagissez de la même façon
que que la droite là-dessus juste pour
information quand même bah non mais la
droite vous avez vu le jeu qu'elle a
joué au Parlement européen là aussi
c'est assez malsin c'est je te tiens tu
me tiens Vous soutenez un commissaire à
l'énergie qu' avait des intérêts dans le
pétrole et puis finalement bah nous on
va soutenir ça c'est un jeu qui est
enfin la Commission européenne ça je le
dis au passage elle est très mal partie
autant la nomination de Jean-Claude
Junker bon c'est un conservateur de
droite mais c'est la droite
conservatrice qui a gagné les élections
européennes il y avait une certaines
logiqu autant là la composition de la
commission européenne honnêtement elle
est très bringballante et elle part très
très mal
pour cet éclairage on va passer à tout
autre chose frç de c'est une passe
d'arme qui a lieu à l'Assemblée
nationale le député UMP Julien Aubert
s'est fait rappeler à l'ordre lors des
débats sur la transition énergétique
vous étiez sûrement dans l'm6 son tort
avoir appelé la présidente de séandre
Sandrine mazotier madame le Président
écoutez le 129 monsieur Aubert merci
Madame euh j'en profite en introduction
puisque vous m'avez madame ça va pas non
plus vous m'avez menacé non non non non
non attendez monsieur Aubert vous n'avez
plus la parole soit vous respectez le la
présidence de séance soit il y a un
problème donc c'est madame la Présidente
je j'utilise les termes de l'acadéie
française rappel à l'ordre avec
inscription au procès verbal faites un
rappel à l'ordre madame le Président
avec inscription procéal vous aurez été
prévenusp je vais vous dire pourquoi
parce que moi j'applique les règles de
l'Académie française qui veulent que la
madame la Présidente c'est la femme du
président et Mad présid le règlement de
l'Assemblée c'est le règlement de
l'Assemblée nationale mais si vous
montrez que dans dans le r inscription
au procès verbal avec inscription un
rappel à l'ORD avec inscription au
procèsverbal voilà et vous voulez ça
peut aller plus loin voà ça peut aller
plus loin dit Sandrine mazotier le
député en question lui a
écopé am indemnité on va toucher son
indemnité parlementaire il y a 139
parlementaires qui viennent à son
secours ça vous choque ça bah disons que
il faut que nos téléspectateurs
comprennent bien que d'abord le
fonctionnement de l'Assemblée il repose
sur l'A du règlement elle respect la
présidence de séance quelle qu'elle soit
et qui est tournante de gauche de droite
donc c'est quelque chose de neutre et
d'ailleurs juste avant la veille il y
avait eu un incident avec Madame Royale
ministre et c'était une présidence de
séance de droite qui a été défendue par
Monsieur Bartolone président de
l'Assemblée nationale donc faut arrêter
avec ces histoires monsieur Aubert c'est
un provocateur
multirécid par qui VI à secours il sait
à quoi il s'attend en faisant des
provocations c'est ce qu'il cherche
d'ailleurs il y en a d'autres des
provocateurs au sein de l'Assemblée
nationale mais il y en a qui assument
les conséquences de leur Gest sur le
fond quand même est-ce que ce genre de
polémique sur une question de de de
genre d'ailleurs ne devient pas un peu
assombrir l'image du débat parlementaire
c'est pétition de 139 députés UMP qui
n'ont rien de mieux à dire queil faut
pas féminiser alors que ça fait depuis
1998 hein que les titres à l'assemblée
sont féminisés et eux avec plus presque
20 ans de retard ils sont encore à
demander qu'on qu'on parle de ce sujet-l
alors qu'il y a quand même d'autres
choses à faire le règlement rien que le
règlement on avance mer mer question
casse-tête et serpent de mer comment
combler le trou de la Sécurité
sociale la ministre Marie soltouren a
détaillé son plan d'action et ses remèes
pour réduire le déficit du régime
général la branche famille va être mise
à contribution l'idée d'une modulation
des allocations familiales fait son
chemin ce qui ne plaît pas forcément à
tout le monde réaction recueilli par
Valérie Brochard et Hugo Lenart ce qui
marche on le casse c'est curieux quand
même pour une fois on a une politique
qui marche qui fait l'envie de l'Europe
entière qui permet à notre pays d'avoir
une vraie démographie et bien on va le
casser ce n'est absolument pas enlever
l'universalité puisqu'il n'est pas
question de revenir sur les prestations
de la politique familiale mais d'en
moduler certaines en fonction des
ressources des familles la bonne réponse
d'abord c'est celle de la réforme
fiscale parce que aujourd'hui on a un
risque c'est que certains ménages qui
ont trouvé un équilibre notamment avec
leur niveau de loyer qui parfois sont
très élevés je le dis quand on a une
grande famille dans des zones très tendu
on pay des niveaux de loyer très élevés
utilise aussi l'existence des
allocations familiales pour conserver un
niveau de vie compatible avec leur vie
de famille et qu'on ne nous fasse pas le
coup de non non non non on touche pas à
l'universalité mais on redistribue quand
même si on module c'est plus une
politique universelle François de rugi
votre position faut-il moduler les
allocations familiales en fonction du du
revenu faut-il imposer les allocations
familiales non moi je ne suis pas
favorable ni à l'intégration des
allocations familiales dans les
déclarations de de revenu parce que ça
veut dire qu'on vous savez ce que ça
veut dire hein on vous donne d'une main
vous la reprend de l'autre ni à la
modulation je on verra hein ce que le
débat parlementaire donne vous demandiez
tout à l'heure s'il y avait une marge de
manœuvre d'amendement dans les débats
budgétaires le groupe socialiste fait
une proposition moi je suis assez
attaché avec les écologistes nous sommes
attachés à l'égalité là c'est le
coprésident du groupe qui parle oui oui
nous sommes attachés à l'égalité des
Françaises et des Français les parents
les enfants aussi parce que aujourd'hui
il y a des inégalités vous savez par
exemple qu'il n'y a pas d'allocation
familiale au premier enfant ça c'est une
inégalité nous nous saons pour qu'il y
en ait de façon égale il y a au
contraire des primes en quelque sorte
pour le 3è et cetera et puis de l'autre
côté il y avait la question du cocient
familial ça nous y sommes revenus et
nous avons bien fait de le faire mais en
contrepartie il faut pas toucher aux
allocations familiales caractère
universel et égalitaire il faut moi je
pense je suis attaché au caractère
universel et égalitaire il y a trop de
défiance dans notre pays tous les
Français sont maintenant en train de se
demander si leurs voisins si leurs
cousins leurs cousin ne gagnent pas plus
queeux ne profitent pas plus que du
système de protection sociale et donc
quand on met de l'égalité on on on remet
de la confiance entre les Français
est-ce que vous estimez que c'est un
débat de fond des réformateurs contre
les ce qui serait plutôt hostile à ces
réformes non je pense que sur la
politique familiale comme sur la
politique de la protection sociale en
général depuis 2 ans et demi comme en
matière souvent budgétaire et fiscale on
a préféré bouger un peu l'existant que
transformer les structures existantes
les faire évoluer et faire les réformes
de structur et là on t qu'on Essie de
toucher petit à petit c'est ça que vous
voulez dire mais non mais on fait plus
ou moins sur l'existant nous nous
pensons depuis le début et nous le
disons sur la politique familiale depuis
le début queil faut faire des réformes
de structure et qui permettent
éventuellement à terme de faire des
économies et qui remettent de la justice
qui remettent de la transparence entre
les Français or quand on fait quand on
joue un peu à la marge plus ou moins et
bien on se retrouve dans les limites
dans lesqu vous conseillez au au
parlementaires et au gouvernement de ne
pas toucher à ce à ce socle et à ce
principe d'égalité vous dites mais nous
nous sommes des réformateurs c'estd nous
nous disons l'égalité c'est-à-dire dès
le premier enfant la même somme pour
tout le monde et on se met d'accord pour
que ça rentre dans l'enveloppe
budgétaire bien évidemment mais en
revanche on ne touche pas à
l'égalitéiversal en ce sens vous allez
faire des propositions au Parlement en
ce sens lesquelles par exemple VI dire
par voie d'amendement mais nous
discuterons avec le groupe socialiste
nous discuterons avec le gouvernement
c'est intéressant aussi que cette
discussion a lieu trop souvent sur le
budget on a l'impression que c'est à
prendre ou à laisser bon bah là il y a
de la discussion tant mieux dans ces
conditions à l'heure actuelle tel que
c'est présenté aujourd'hui vous votez ce
budget sur la sécurité sociale ou pas
attendez nous avons déjà le budget de
l'État qui qui va être
examiné je pose la même question ce soit
pour bu le financement de la sécurité
sociale quelle est la position des ver
nous notre position elle est simple
c'est que nous travaillons avec des
amendements avec les autres groupes de
la majorité avec le gouvernement pour
faire faire évoluer le budget de l'État
et le budget de la Sécurité sociale et
au vu des évolutions qui auront été
faites ou pas et bien nous le voterons
ou pas Cécile Duflot j'en parlais tout à
l'heure qui est dans votre groupe dit à
l'heure actuelle tel que c'est
aujourd'hui moi c'est hors de question
je ne vote pas je vote contre c'est un
avis personnel mais moi je suis
coprésident de groupe donc je vous dis
l'état de nos discussions au sein du
groupe et c'est la démarche que nous
avons eu depuis 2 ans et demi compris
quand Cécile Duflot était membre du
gouvernement l'année dernière par
exemple nous avions dit le budget n'est
pas vot en l'état parce que sur la
fiscalité écologique la contribution
climaténergie ce qu'on appelait parfois
la taxe carbone il y avait du flou quand
il y a eu la présentation du budget on
ne savait même pas où on allait et nous
avons obtenu dans la discussion que la
contribution climat énergie soit mise en
œuvre et elle monte en puissance
d'ailleurs au fil des années et on y
revient pas et nous avons voté le budget
l'année dernière vous mettrez la
pression et Cécile Duflot d'ailleurs le
souhaitait l'année dernière alors on va
passer à une autre proposition explosive
c'est Manuel Vals qui a relancé comme ça
en passant le débat au détour d'une
petite phrase sur le montant la durée
des allocations chômage gros dossier
François Hollande reste évasif sur le
sujet renvoyant le dossier aux
partenaires sociaux les syndicat eu voie
rouge Marie Labat nous explique tout ça
les nouvelles conditions d'indemnisation
du chômage à peine en vigueur le premier
ministre relance déjà le débat lundi
dernier manuel Val sen visite à Londres
évoque en off devant la presse
britannique le fait de repenser la durée
et le montant de l'assurance chômage à
l'Assemblée nationale hier il réitère
ses propos chômeurs c'est un débat
légitime il faut l'aborder sans
caricature c'est une exigence quand on
connaît ce haut niveau de chômage depuis
des années et cette réforme c'est celle
qui doit assurer la pérenité aussi de
notre modèle social même s'il doit se
réformer et se réinventer en déplacement
en Italie François Hollande lui reste
plus évasif il y a demain une discussion
qui s'engage entre les partenaires
sociaux pour la modernisation du
dialogue social pour favoriser là aussi
a la représentation des salariés mais
également la simplification des
procédures il y a la loi qui est prévue
sur justement la croissance et notamment
le travail le travail le dimanche il y a
suffisamment de sujets pour que nous
soyons bien occupés que nous montrions
que nous faisons des réformes utiles à
l'emploi on fait pas des réformes pour
des réformes on fait des réformes pour
qu'il ait plus de croissance et plus
d'emploi et notamment pour les jeunes
pour les partenaires sociaux c'est un
débat à contettemps je trouve que c'est
pas le moment de alors que les nouvelles
règles entre en vigueur qu'elles sont
positivesell permettent elles sont de
l'incitation positive pas punitive
positive à la reprise d'emploi on nous
dit il faudra revoir les règles car les
renégociations des règles
d'indemnisation chômage passent
obligatoirement par un accord syndicat
patronat le prochain devrait avoir lieu
en 2016 alors on voit le discours un peu
cacophonique en tout les positions pas
très clair de l'exécutif sur le sujet
vous vous dites quoi il faut ouvrir le
débat c'est nécessaire ou pas du tout
moi j'ai été un peu étonné par les
petites phrases qui sont rapportées dans
la presse et qui sont prêtées au Premier
ministre dans l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée
nationale en réponse aux questions des
députés il a été un peu plus clair et de
fait il donnait moins l'impression de
vouloir remettre en cause
l'indemnisation du chômage moi je vais
vous dire notre position elle est assez
simple c'est pas parce que les
indemnités chômage sont trop élevées que
des demandeurs d'emploi des chômeurs euh
sont dissuadés de reprendre des emplois
c'est d'abord parce qu'il y a pas
beaucoup d'offres d'emploi mais c'est
aussi parce que trop souvent des
personnes qui reprennent ou prendra une
activité temporaire partielle et cetera
perdent leurs indemnités ou leurs
allocations et là ils sont dissuadés en
effet de se REM TR pas un sujet tabou
pasjet Tab moi je il y a pas de sujet
tabou en politique he ça c'est pas c'est
pas c'est pas le sujet oui mais
justement c'est le problème si vousoulez
c'est les postures d'un côté parce que
ça ressemble un peu à une posture he moi
je vais réformer le marché du travail je
vais réformmer l'anisation du chômage
puis après qu'est-ce qui se passe hein
et puis d'un autre côté il y qui a les
postures de l'autre côté qui disent
attention ça y est on est en train de
faire le modèle britannique ou que
sais-je encore la protection sociale en
France elle est d'un haut niveau et nous
on est attaché à la protéger à la
financer aussi parce que le problème on
en parle pas beaucoup c'est l'équilibre
financier de l'assurance chômage qui
n'est pas garanti qui est en lourd
déficit et là aussi comme on a accumulé
des déficits par le passé on n'est pas
capable d'y faire face quand le chômage
augmente fortement comme c'est le cas
actuellement mais la réforme des droits
rechargeable au chômage pour les
chômeurs c'est une très bonne réforme
très bonne réforme et ça il faut la
mettre en application maintenant comme
c'était prévu il est dans la posture le
Premier ministre ben là je regrette que
sur ce genre de propos oui ça donne
l'impression d'être un peu des des
postures et je pense qu'en plus lui il a
plutôt l'habitude d'être en effet un
réformateur et pragmatique donc je ne
saurait que souhaiter qu'il le soit
davantage sur ce sujet comme sur
d'autres est-ce qu'il fait une erreur de
stigmatiser les chômeurs personnes qui
sont déjà moi j'ai pas senti son
discours comme une stigmatisation des
chômeurs mais tout ce qui ressemblerait
à une stigmatisation des chômeurs serait
erreur là aussi le ministre du Travail
avait fait des déclarations monsieur
repsamen qui ont pu semmer le trouble
sur les contrôles des chômeurs parce
qu'il y a des chômeurs qui cherch pas
travil c'est le cas il il y a quelques
départements aujourd'hui qui font cette
recherche à pe l'emploi mais moi je
trouve ça tout à fait normal qu'il ait
des contrôles à partir de moment où vous
avez une allocation une indemnisation
bien vous êtes contrôlé moi-même j'ai
été demandeur d'emploi indemnisé à
certaine périodes plus indemnisé à
d'autres donc je sais ce que c'est mais
pour autant on va pas laisser croire que
s'il y a 3500000 chômeurs dans la
catégorie A et bien c'est parce que il y
a 3500000 personnes qui ne veulent pas
reprendre un emploi l'accompagnement à
l'emploi en France est l'un des plus
faibles d'Europe c'est qu'il est plus
faible qu'en Grande-Bretagne par exemple
et sur les ses sociaux est-ce qu'il faut
une loi sujet qui est aussi dans
l'actualité demi non mais là il y a une
négociation qui s'ouvre partenair pour
la négociation entre les patrons les
syndicats patronaux et les syndicats de
salariés oui mais pour le chômage ça
doit être l'an prochain bon si il y a
des choses qui peuvent aboutir parce que
des effets de seuil en effet on voit
bien qu'il y a des entreprises ça moi
j'en rends compte qui me dit je préfère
ne pas passer à 51 et rester à 48 ou 49
salariés parce que je vais avoir des
contraintes supplémentaires si on peut
lisser un peu cela oui mais on va pas
supprimer la représentation des salariés
on en a besoin dans les entreprises
d'avoir des représentants des salariés
qui justement permettent du dialogue
social et quand il y a du dialogue
social justement permettre de faire des
accords entre les patrons et les
salariés notamment sur les questions de
modulation du temps de travail notamment
sur les questions de conditions de
travail de formation et cetera on va
passer au jeudi avec un enterrement de
première classe celle de l'école taxe
pour ça
deorie bah on imagine que vous avez dû
bondir he quand vous avez entendu cette
information les transporteurs routiers
ont eu bien de cause la taxe poids lourd
est abandonné la ministre de l'écologie
Segolen royale l'a annoncé c'est une
suspension sinédiée a-t-elle dit Thomas
soulier c'est lors de cette réunion que
tout a basculé face à la ministre les
transporteurs routiers réclament
l'abandon de écotax il menace de faire
grève et de bloquer les routes résultat
C Goolen Royal fait marche arrière le pH
po lourd est suspendu je préfère faire
cela que de voir le pays
bloquer les camions bloquer les
routes bloquer l'économie et se faire du
mal à eux-mêmes ils étaaient pas
demandeur d'ailleurs de se faire du mal
à eux-mêm c'est c'est pas facile de
déclencher des mouvements mais une fois
qu'ils sont déclenchés on sait pas
comment ça s'arrête pour remplacer le pH
poiss lourd le gouvernement pourrait
taxer les profits des société
d'autoroute un groupe de travail a été
mis en place ce recul du gouvernement ne
satisfait personne au sein même de la
majorité je suis très déçux et
scandalisé que le gouvernement a décidé
de suspendre à nouveau cette taxe déjà
il y a un an elle a été suspendue
aujourd'hui la question est de savoir
qui va payer qui va payer pour
l'entretien des routes qui va payer pour
les dépenses de santé et la pollution de
l'air ça va être encore une fois les
Français ce n'est pas acceptable je
rappelle que l'cotax a été voté par le
Parlement il a même été voté à
l'unanimité donc on ne peut pas
abandonner du jour au
lendemain une disposition
que les parlementaires ont voulu cette
annonce pour étendre les relations avec
les écologistes en plein débat à
l'Assemblée sur la transition
énergétique les débats reprennent ce
vendredi dans l'hémicycle Noël ma mère a
déjà annoncé qu'en représaille il ne
voterait pas le texte erreur politique
bah c'est plus grave que cela c'est un
sujet de Fond hein la taxe poour c'était
la mise en œuvre enfin en France de
façon claire transparente du principe
non seulement pollueur payeur mais plus
on use les routes plus on contribue
quand même financièrement à leur
entretien et à leur rénovation voir à
leur
construction en dehors plus grave qu'une
erreur politique ah ben moi je pense que
c'est sur le fond c'est assez grave pour
encore une fois le principe
pollueurpayeur pour les le budget de
l'État là aussi hein puisque c'est
encore un trou alors que l'on crée je ne
sais pas comment on va le reboucher on
voit bien ce qui se profile c'est donc
augmenter les taxes sur les carburants
des particuliers alors je vais vous dire
au bout d'un moment est-ce que il faut
que les il y a des associations qui se
créent d'automobilistes et qui disent
nous on va aller bloquer les zones
logistiques par exemple voyez on va les
bloquer on va on va mettre les les
Français les uns contre les autres les
camionneurs contre les automobiles alors
que les automobiles subissent déjà la
présence de 30 camions sur les routes
vous seriez contre une augmentation de
la taxe sur le diesel on parle de 2
centimes plus encore 2 centimes ce qui
ferait quasiment bah c'est en effet du
rafistolage qu'il y ait une réflexion et
ensuite des mesures prises nous nous le
sou sur la fiscalité des carburants avec
y compris une baisse sur l'essence pour
inciter à basculer pour que le marché
automobile se rééquilibre pour que les
pratiques changent évidemment nous nous
pensons que la fiscalité est un outil
qui permet c'est pas le seul le
changement de comportement on l'a dit
souvent c'est quand on touche au
porte-monnaie qu'on agit vraiment sur
les comportements mais alors là dire que
pour les routiers simplement parce
qu'ils ont menacé de paralyser la France
mais qu'est-ce que c'est que ça par que
ça veut dire que les routiers sont plus
forts que les écologistes au-delà de oui
mais c'est veut dire que une minorité
une toute petite minorité des intérêts
particuliers peuvent mettre à bas non
seulement l'intérêt général mais la
volonté majoritaire parce que si vous
faites des sondages vous verrez que les
Français sont très largement
majoritaires favorbl à cette taxe po
franis de ça veut dire aussi que le
gouvernement et c'est royal a cédé à la
pression des lobby à l'ultimatum des
routiers je vous dis sur les transports
ça commence à faire beaucoup vous avez
eu la réforme ferroviaire avec une grève
à la SNCF et du coup la réforme
ferroviaire a été considérablement
rabottée alors qu'elle avait été
négociée avec la entre la direction de
la SNCF et les principaux syndicats vous
avez eu le projet d'Air France d'avoir
une nouvelle compagnie européenne
Transavia qui a été retiré grève despil
de Lig toute petite minorité également
et là maintenant la taxe poid lourd mais
je sais pas comment on va pouvoir
réformer le secteur des transports qui
en a pourtant bien besoin puisque tout
le monde dit depuis des années que le
tout routier ce n'est pas une solution
pour le transport des marchand solution
et surtout qu'est-ce qui va
remplacer parle de mettre à contribution
les sociétés d'autor- est-ce que ça va
suffir se finir mettre à contribution
les sociétés d'autoroute ça veut dire
que les péages hein que payent les
automobilistes et aussi les camions mais
les automobilistes principalement sur
les autoroutes vont augmenter et en plus
pour le transport par camion bah écoutez
moi j'attends de voir ce que je sais
c'est que les prélèvements ça a déjà été
étudier ça les prélèvements sur les
bénéfices des sociétés d'autoroute c'est
vrai que les les bénéfices sont
peut-être très élevés qu'on pourrait en
prélever une partie mais ça sera
peut-être 100 millions 200 millions la
taxe pourour c'était un milliard où
est-ce qu'on va trouver le milliard par
ailleurs le contrat ecomove on va le
dénoncer comme ça sans que ça coûte rien
au budget de l'État c'est pas possible
et bien la réponse est dans la question
he c'est-à-dire que c'est le budget de
l'État qui va payer c'est qu'on perd une
recette et on crée une dépense vous
savez que nous à l'Assemblée nationale
au Sénat on n pas le droit de déposer
des amendements qui feraiit simplement
perdre une recette ou simplement
augmenter une dépense et là l'État par
une décision qui en effet mériterait par
ailleurs un vote du Parlement fait
perdre une recette et créer une dépense
Françis d'orig on entend Christophe car
dans le reportage qui dit la loi a été
votée par le Parlement comment à
plusieurs reprises alors comment est-il
possible aujourd'hui de la supprimer
comme ça du jour au lendemain bah parce
que le gouvernement s'arroge le droit de
dire une une fiscalité qui avait été
créée je vais pas l'appliquer mais il va
bien falloir repasser devant le
Parlement il va bien falloir repasser
devant le Parlement notamment au moment
de la discussion budgétaire pour dire
les choses
clairement et qu'est-ce que vous direz
ah ben nous nous avons déjà dit au mois
de juillet rendez compte qu'on en avait
parlé au mois de juillet on a voté un
dispositif au mois de juillet c'était la
taxe poil lourd réduite de
moitié et là on on on va alors ça même
pas 6 mois on va en reparler la semaine
prochaine à l'Assemblée lors de la
discussion budgétaire et évidemment nous
poserons les questions concrètes sur le
coût de cette suspension sur où est-ce
qu'on trouve l'argent en contrepartie et
ainsi de suite nous par ailleurs sur les
infrastructures de transport vous savez
qu'on a plein de propositions à faire y
compris pour faire des économie un
certain nombre de projets faramineux je
suis bien placé pour en parler dans mon
département le projet d'aéroport notre
des land ou d'autres alors on multiplie
les annonces d'un côté le grand canal se
Nord ici le TGV Poitier limoge là-bas
l'aéroport de notre des Landes et en
revanche ont réduit les financements
quoi qu'ou improvisation non je pense
que cgolen royale avait dit depuis le
début qu'elle était contre cette taxe et
que vous savez je crois que les premiers
surprises c'étaient les organisations de
transporteurs routiers qui ne
s'attendaient pas à cela dans cette
réunionorité finalement ah bah elle non
puisque elle elle a obtenu gain de cause
par rapport à sa position de départ moi
je je trouve que c'est plutôt le
gouvernement dans son ensemble qui du
coup parce que c'est un mauvais signal
pour l'écologie mais c'est aussi un
mauvais signal pour conduire des
réformes et des changements dans notre
pays parce que là vous donnez un sacré
coup de pouce à toutes les corporations
si minoritair soit-ell contre l'intérêt
général qui diront moi si je peux
bloquer les routes al évidment vaut
mieux pouvoir bloquer les routes bloquer
le rail ou bloquer les aérop estce que
vous AZ encore confiance en Colen royale
ah bah sur les autres sujets oui sur ce
sujet là on a toujours une divergence on
le savait très bien hein mais c'est
surtout moi par rapport à l'ensemble du
gouvernement nous en avions parlé
d'ailleurs avec Michel Sapin qui est
ministre des Finances et qui nous avait
dit mais c'est une affaire à 2 milliards
d'euros ça crée un trou dans le budget
de l'État entre la perte de recette et
la dépense d'indemnisation des comov ben
en tout cas j'ai entendu déjà Michel
Sapin dire que c'était quand même pas
simple de compenser cette confiance ah
sur cette question de la fiscalité
écologique c'est sûr que là la confiance
c'est considérablement aménuiser alors
on va s'intéresser un petit peu à vous
si vous voulez bien on va parler de
votre i
réputation François d'orig on va parler
de la iréputation c'est ce qui se passe
sur le web sur internet sur facebook
surtout notamment avec Astrid de Villen
spécialiste du web pour pour les chaînes
parlementaires bonjour Astrid bonjour
Michel alors vous êtes penché un petit
peu sur la réputation de de François de
de rugie on trouve de tout dans les lmes
du web qu'est-ce que vous avez trouvé
sur notre invité bien on va déjà aller à
la surface du web regardez un petit peu
ce qu'on trouve quand on tape François
de rugi dans un moteur de recherche on
tombe d'abord sur votre blog plutôt
moderne et bien mise à jour sur votre
page de députés sur le site de
l'Assemblée nationale on va avoir tout
ça et sur vos réseaux sociaux qui sont
eux aussi très bien référencé donc c'est
vraiment ce qu'on peut appeler une bonne
irréputation monsieur d'origine ne vous
inquiétez pas en revanche on va aller
voir quand même ce qui se passe sur vos
réseaux sociaux vous êtes sur Facebook
et vous êtes suivi par
5701 personnes c'est pas mal mais vous
pouvez faire beaucoup mieux PASP
exactement alors vous êtes quand même
devant votre homologue au Sénat ça va
vous faire plaisir hein Jean-Vincent
placer puisque lui il est il a seulement
1600 fans en revanche si on va voir chez
fais la course c'est vrai bon alorsutê
que vous devriez en tout cas barbara
Pompili est devant vous regardez 6121
fans elle a donc 1000 fans de plus que
vous il va falloir rattraper tout ça
surtout qu'elle a été élue bien après
vous donc sur Twitter François de rugie
est en revanche devant est làdessus vous
là c'est vrai que vous vous la Battez
1000 followers de plus que barbara
Pompili vous êtes donc décidément
totalement paritaire puisquelle est
meilleure sur Facebook et vous sur
Twitter on va aller observer tout de
suite votre profil Twitter et ce qu'on
aime le plus et bien c'est votre photo
de profil elle a été très bien choisi
vous allez voir en image fond vert qui
fait écolo et qui se repère très bien
dans le flux Twitter c'est pas mal parce
que tout à l'heure on est passé un petit
peu vite sur votre page Facebook et il y
a quand même des dossiers qui traînent
dans vos photos Facebook regardez
celle-ci alors évidemment très
républicaine elle a été prise à tous les
coups au début de l'informatique
regardez mug sur le côté hémicycle
derrière sacré mise en scène en tout cas
François de rugi vous êtes un véritable
tweetos vous n'arrêtez pas de tweeter
depuis que votre compte Twitter a été
ouvert en 2012 vous avez envoyé plus de
14000 M sage on a fait le calcul ça fait
à peu près 15 tweets par jour c'est
beaucoup certains disent beaucoup trop
mais au moins vous êtes réactif vous
êtes notamment illustré au moment du
mariage pour tous alors que certains à
l'UMP proposaient d'interdire Twitter
dans l'émicycle vous vous y êtes
totalement opposé comme on va le voir
avec un un tweet c'est l'interaction
entre justement un un l'émicycle ça peut
très vite devenir une bulle et le public
nous ne sommes là que parce que nous
avons une légitimité éctoriale et vous
savez qu'à la source de l'assemblée il y
a la transparence le lien avec la
population tout moment l'Assemblée
nationale il y a toujours quelques
places réservé dans le public pour une
personne qui arrive au dernier moment
alors le twitter c'est la prolongation
de ce principe as on va voir aussi c'est
le bonus avec une photo oui alors cette
photo c'est votre photo de couverture
sur Facebook et elle est très
révélatrice regardez François de rugi
dans la cour d'honneur de l'Assemblée
nationale portable à la main certains
disent que vous êtes même totalement
accro à votre smartphone on a donc une
question est-ce que de temps en temps
vous décrochez ah oui bien sûr d'abord
contrairement à d'autres je l'éteins
tous les soirs parce que je ne veux pas
que les ones me bombardent pendant la
nuit et il m'arrive de ne pas être
joignable parce que je suis en vacances
en weekend ou aut non non ça alors là je
vous dire on a même plaisanté fin août
vous savez qu'il y a eu un petit
événement politique avec la démission du
gouvernement et moi j'étais en train de
faire du vélo dans en Gironde
et je restais joignable avec des moments
évidemment liés à la géographie et
j'avais prévu ça de faire ça en famille
et oui j'avais mon téléphone mais je
n'étais pas en permanence joignable il
faut savoir s'arrêter mais je pense que
c'est notre rôle euh d'être et notamment
Twitter permet ça ou Facebook d'être en
lien avec nos concitoyens comme moi je
suis dans la rue on m'arrête je discute
je fais des réunions de contreendu de
mandat si vous savez c'est pas que ça si
c'était que ça évidemment ça ait un côté
virtuel mais comme je le dis toujours à
mes concitoyens de Nantes orvau et
satron dans ma circonscription vous
savez que vous avez un député sous la
main donc vous m'avez sous la main
physiquement présent euh ou par d'autres
modes d'interpellation est-ce qu'il y a
des tweets que vous regrettez oh pe
toujours en regretter mais moi
contrairement à d'autres vous pourrez
vérifier je je n'en ai pas effacé ou ça
a dû m'arriver une ou deux fois et oui
il y a des choses qui sont parce que moi
Twitter je considérais au début que
c'était un autre mode de relation si
c'est uniquement pour copier les
communiqués de presse qu'on fait déjà
que mettre un lien avec cette émission
c'est très intéressant mais ça n'ajoute
pas grand-chose en plus et donc moi je
voulais que ce soit aussi un lien c'est
un d'ailleurs un point commun que
j'avais avec Cécile Duflot on lui a
reproché aussi à elle de faire des
choses personnelles et elle m'a dit
quand elle est devenu ministre qu'elle
avait dû arrêter mais elle m'a dit toi
continue tu es député tu as plus de
liberté c'est vrai que maintenant que
j'ai plus de personnes qui me suivent
plus de responsabilité je fais aussi
attention et que oui parfois je
m'autolimite en effet par rapport à des
choses plus personnelles ou plus
humoristiques on compte sur vous quand
même pour nous retweeter merci beaucoup
Stre de Villain katien on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine avec plaisir et très
bonne suite de programme sur les chaînes
parlementaires merci à tous de votre
fidélité bye
bye